il et elle sont dix juste derrière moi
nous tous qu'on sait c'est que dedans il
y a un couple de personnes qui vivent
ensemble et qui s'aiment un deuxième
couple
identique on sait pas s'ils sont
hétérosexuels homosexuels on a un couple
qui est lié par simplement une amitié et
un couple qui est lié par un lien de
fratrie donc ça veut dire que s'il y a
10 personnes il nous reste deux
personnes inconnues à trouver on a la
liste derrière j'accueille celle qui a
tué le Game dans la première vidéo avec
un sans faute et je suis très
en fait je vais tout trouver j'essaie
juste d'être à la hauteur
en plus il me rajoutait une brique moi
va falloir je trouve les métiers
il y a un métier en rapport avec la
science un audiovisuel journaliste
patrimoine horlogerie c'est rare c'est
un gène riche journaliste de nouveau à
deux journalistes le chiffre vente et
ingénierie de nouveau non ça va je
t'aiderait aussi là dessus quelques
idées ceux qui ont des lunettes
forcément on est catégories
écoute merci déjà beaucoup d'être là je
suis content qu'on refasse une vidéo
ensemble pour ceux qui connaissent pas
du tout explique-leur en deux secondes
ce que c'est le cabaret
qui existe dans lequel j'ai la chance de
mettre à l'honneur en lumière des
artistes qui moi m'impressionnent et on
emmène les gens dans un monde voilà
féerique et je crois qu'en ce moment
c'est très important et vous êtes en
train de voir des images de merde
pendant qu'on parle je vous mettrai les
liens dans la description parce que
c'est à Paris une fois par mois c'est
également en tournée dans des belles
salles en plus bref allez voir c'est une
super alors moi ce que je te propose
c'est qu'on pioche deux personnes on les
met ici on les passe à la questionner un
petit peu tu vois il faudra qu'on
retienne au fur et à mesure ce qu'on est
en train de penser sur les liens
possibles on fait comprendre un homme ou
une femme et on essaie de voir un peu
déjà s'ils sont un peu connectés ou
frère et sœur ou une intention sur ces
deux personnes Nicolas venait ici s'il
vous plaît peut-être un petit peu vous
étudier pourquoi tu les as sélectionnés
je sais pas je trouve qu'il y a quelque
chose peut-être de ressemblance
peut-être sur le nez sur la bouche en
fait il crisse un peu leur bouche de la
même façon je sais pas je trouvais qu'il
y avait une petite ressemblance petite
ressemblance ok vous vous connaissez
déjà la base vous êtes jamais rencontré
il
identifie très très bien les mensonges
vous êtes rencontrés il y a combien de
temps 20 minutes une heure
il faut aussi que je réfléchisse à vos
métiers en plus
ingénierie journaliste la science vente
tu me conseillerais pas non
patrimoine
[Rires]
parce qu'il a réagi il était très gêné
par la question alors est-ce que c'est
parce qu'il voit pas de quoi tu parles
ou est-ce que parce que tu as tapé dans
le milieu direct je vais quand même
noter ça moi je vais mettre un petit
Nico à côté d'ici parce que tu as fait
ça d'accord moi je vais mettre une
petite option ici pour clarifier c'est
le métier le plus original qui a ici
mais après je sais que mon cerveau est
biaisé par ce tatouage incroyable que tu
as et le fait d'avoir un prénom très
original alors que tu ne l'as pas choisi
toi-même évidemment la vente aussi la
vente en général
l'acheter parce que c'est du noir le
noir c'est la couleur la plus facile à
faire à placer rien que pour ça j'ai pas
envie de donner plus de plus d'arguments
politicienne
je vois bien génial je sais pas pourquoi
ingénieur
de tout ça fait sérieux en tout cas en
fait tu nous inspires quelque chose de
sérieux tu vois mais je suis un peu
comme j'ai envie de te confier de
l'argent plus je sais pas pourquoi moi
je pense qu'il se connaissent pas en
réalité parce qu'en fait c'est qu'on
rigole ils se regardent pas avec
amusement etc ils sont même pas
synchronisés au niveau des gestes tu
vois elle allait comme ça elle est comme
ça le professionnalisme il pourrait être
ami avec ce monsieur
Jocelyn et Nico tous les deux
positions
de tête quand il a dit ça vous avez fait
ça aussi parce que tu es fort pour te
rattraper donc il est pas en couple et
surtout il y a des choses il y a des
choses à rattraper apparemment
en tout cas ou alors c'est un gros gros
bluffeur qui abattre toutes les
Oumou Marie il était trop pensé après il
y avait vraiment toi qui a regretté de
dire merde j'aurais pu aller encore plus
loin dans le truc
je pense que ton jeu est très perturbant
dans le sens où j'ai l'impression que
tout le monde se ressent maintenant
regarde quelque chose dans le regard
quelque chose dans les sourcils quelque
chose même dans le nez il y a un truc
qui m'épate moi c'est que depuis qu'il
est arrivé Jocelyn il a jamais jeté un
œil vers nous
je pense et ça pourrait les lier en tant
qu'ami c'est pas mal en plus ils sont un
peu complémentaires parce que regarde
dans cette forme de timidité il y en a
un qui reste un peu plus en réserve et
l'autre qui prend le lead toutes les
deux secondes tu viens de te croiser tes
jambes parce que il les croise
j'ai la bouche
on tourne autour de quelque chose en
tout cas je trouve qu'il y a une
ressemblance qui parfois lit les gens en
amitié on se ressemble on se
connecte quoi je mets ça c'est pas grave
et dans le marbre moi après Jocelyn je
le verrai bien sur tu vois par rapport
au Babou qu'il a audiovisuel ou
journalisme un truc comme ça
je sais pas mais plus
on a vraiment de te donner son argent
moi je suis pas mal sur amitié je veux
bien qu'on se le fiche
en tout cas si vous étiez au même
endroit au même moment je pense que vous
seriez devenu amis 25 ans 25 ans et toi
tu as quel âge 29 et toi
comme il a réagi à tête fin d'année je
me demande si la réagi parce qu'il
connaît sa date de naissance et que
c'était en train de le bluffer que je
trouve toi aussi tu t'es dit fin d'année
il parle à qui parce que moi aussi fin
d'année mais toi tu es peut-être fin
d'année début d'année toi tu es
peut-être poisson toi ouais c'est ça non
ça c'est quand même énorme incroyable on
se prend deux autres personnes toi tu
proposais couple proposé
il y en a un qui sourit je vois qu'on
dit quoi
Valentin je le voyais bien un peu
déconnecté du système parce que je
trouve très très très spectateur et donc
contrairement aux autres qui se font
attention à pas regarder la personne à
qui sont venus lui je le sens tellement
libre tu vois que je le vois bien un peu
en solo tu m'as dit ton prénom c'est
Thomas
Thomas et Audrey donc tu as quel âge
environ Audrey 35 à quel âge environ 38
c'est pas mal qu'est-ce que tu en
penses
juste de toi
Thomas Thomas il a un petit peu un petit
truc de super-héros tu sais oui je vois
il y a de la force il y a du
raisonnement il y a du calme aussi il y
a beaucoup d'analyses science tu connais
le chat de shringer
[Rires]
ce que je pressant par exemple moi je te
vois bien être assez forte dans la
gestion d'un groupe le management avec
la planification ce genre de choses tu
vois et j'ai pas de je vois pas de
choses comme ça qui s'en approche quoi
tu aimes bien les tatouages j'en ai pas
non mais d'une manière générale tu as
priori positive négative non positif
positifs un peu partout je veux voir si
il est prêt à s'embrouiller avec sa meuf
ou pas
et toi tu as beaucoup de tatouages du
coup
histoire personnelle du coup oui
d'accord
combien tu as d'enfants
marrant des idées en comptant son nombre
d'enfant
alors il y a lui un déclaré
et toi tu as combien d'enfants
c'est vraiment un couple potentiel
très creux dessus moi je propose qu'on
se le note et qu'on continue à faire nos
variations en fait ce qui est très
trompeur c'est le couple d'inconnu parce
qu'en fait on peut mettre tout le monde
dedans
si Nico et Josse ils étaient frangins
parfois la ressemblance nous attire et
du coup on peut créer des liens d'amitié
donc je trouve que c'est soit amis mais
il y a quelque chose en tout cas vous
avez toujours la même position
corporelle là aussi tous les deux non
c'est des frères
cette famille donc ça veut dire en
amitié on aurait pas trouvé l'amitié
dans ces cas-là on pourrait peut-être
chercher l'amitié il y a deux filles qui
sont maquillées de la même façon et
parfois c'est quelque chose qu'on se
donne entre copines les tips make-up
allez je vous laisse vous rasoir s'il
vous plaît vous avez été convoqué par
Clara Morgane à cause de maquillage
ressemblant veuillez vous expliquer sur
ce point tu te maquille toujours comme
ça
quand elle sort de chez elle du coup
maquillage justement et je sais faire
que le parce qu'elle t'a montré non
regarde beaucoup sa copine
de travailler en audiovisuel dans la
technique
et du coup toi aussi je te vois aussi
dans le journalisme peut-être plus
technique et plus on interview
par leur métier ou leurs études dans le
sens de métier qui sont les amitiés
en ingénieur sinon quelque chose
regarde elle est très gênée que j'ai dit
ça non
d'accord
j'ai gratté là où il fallait en tout cas
en amitié je trouve que vous matiez de
fou quoi
tellement d'attente à chaque fois qu'il
la regarde tu es là en mode couleur
on le dit maintenant on le dit plus tard
donc en fait on aurait quoi on aurait
plus que un couple à trouver et deux
inconnus sachant que je pense que
Valentin ne connaît personne
c'est à dire qu'il y a aussi une
deuxième personne qui serait venue toute
seule parmi les personnes qui en a pas
parlé moi j'ai un peu rangé pierre et
Claire via dans ma tête ensemble je te
le dis fais que si je garde j'ai cette
hypothèse là ça veut dire qu'il me reste
récemment ta qui connaîtrait personne et
qui serait plutôt là pour le coup moi je
vois bien
ingénieur sciences plutôt pour elle
je suis d'accord il nous manque un
couple il nous manque un couple et du
coup ce que je te propose c'est que on
se repositionne différemment on met tout
le monde en ligne on commence à former
des couples de liens qu'on voilà qu'on
pressant et on va peut-être y voir un
peu plus clair pour après faire des
derniers switchs
ok on fait ça on va commencer à faire
nos hypothèses on les a bien mis tous
les 10 en ligne on va leur donner des
panneaux pour les ranger entre eux nous
on range des gens c'est ça notre métier
famille alors on est d'accord on en
donne un Josselin et un à Nico c'est ça
et dans ces cas-là est-ce que Valentin
et Jocelyn vous pouvez changer de place
comme ça on va on va commencer à ranger
les ranger les gens dans des cases en
couple un peu safe après c'est pas figé
on pourra changer
Audrey et Thomas mais aussi elle
pourrait je sais que c'est peut-être pas
ton idée mais elle pourrait être avec
Valentin de dire qu'Audrey peut être un
peu avec tout le monde
parce que là on peut être très embêté
par ça ok Audrey c'est sûr elle est
impliquée dans chacun des couples
et ça c'est est-ce que est-ce que pour
l'instant on le donne à Valentin ou à
Thomas
est-ce que Valentin et Samantha vous
pouvez changer de place s'il vous plaît
parfait merci beaucoup comme ça on pose
ce couple là
des autres parce qu'on voit ce qui se
passe
comme quoi c'est bien lui qui est des
sols parce que lui il était chaud pour
le faire
vraiment alors qu'elle a fait non mon
gars même pas la blague les amis on
était assez safe toi et moi sur sur
Sofia et Sarah et Sarah tu peux changer
de PLACE avec Claire via s'il te plaît
genre ah ça se voit qu'on est ensemble
et du coup et oui et du coup forcément
les deux solos ce serait Samantha qui me
paraît plutôt crédible et du coup Thomas
où j'ai pas encore d'avis parce que je
le voyais en couple moi au départ au
moins on a fait un premier jet c'est pas
mal ce couple la plus je le vois plus je
l'aime bien nos deux copines plus ça
plus c'est d'une évidence les deux
frangins aussi regarde mais c'est Pipo
et Mario c'est les jumeaux mais regarde
ils ont les mêmes oreilles d'ailleurs
marqué regarde jamais assez les oreilles
c'est vrai il nous reste donc Thomas on
avait un petit doute sur le fait qu'il
soit solo ou en couple avec Audrey s'il
est en couple avec Audrey ça veut dire
que ça nous re libère Valentin en solo
ça m'entend en solo ça va je trouve que
là c'est le somme d'être en solo c'est
crédible puisque je dis réfléchis
interroge là encore fait tout ce que tu
veux la torture est acceptable et moi je
vais commencer à poser les métiers aussi
un petit peu devant pour voir compliqué
de faire semblant de pas se connaître
c'est sûr
qui soit en couple ou solo pour moi
c'est lui qui vend des trucs
science pour l'instant je sais pas trop
ingénieur journaliste ça c'est horloge
je le laisse devant car il y a pour
l'instant voilà ça c'est les cadeaux un
peu qui nous restent ça j'ai mis en
fonction de ce que je pense non
je sais pas mais plus dans les
statistiques dans les de collecter de la
donnée de l'analyser pour prendre une
décision tu vois notre couple on le
garde comme ça ou tu les vois bah ouais
c'est toi qui les voyais ensemble au
départ d'ailleurs on imagine le matin tu
bois quoi le matin toi tu vois rien toi
tu bois quoi rien et toi tu bois quoi ok
donc l'eau au moment
au moment il se retrouve pas du tout
pour le petit déjeuner du coup
téléphoner du coup l'image elle
fonctionne pas est-ce qu'on demande à
Pierre où on en est genre combien
d'erreurs on a ah c'est pas mal ça on
voudrait savoir concernant les liens
uniquement les jobs on fera ça plus tard
si on a une ou des erreurs dans ce cas
là c'est oui mais je veux le savoir vous
avez bien travaillé je vois deux
erreurs deux erreurs ben forcément oui
deux erreurs
et là maintenant il voit quatre erreurs
là avec Clara on fixe ça moi pour moi je
valide ça je te suis c'est moi qui te
suis parce que c'est beaucoup des
conclusions quand même combien d'erreurs
[Rires]
pour tout le monde alors comme quoi vous
allez tous très bien ensemble les
couples les amis ça marche très bien
parce qu'on s'est beaucoup basé sur toi
si si vous vous souvenez c'est elle qui
dit non mais là les deux ont même
maquillage
de la même façon et parfois c'est
quelque chose qu'on se qu'on se donne
entre copines les tips les deux là je
les sens bien de la même famille
on essaye d'intellectualiser comme tout
ça mais franchement spontanément c'est
toi qui a qui a fait les bons binômes
donc vous vous êtes quoi vous êtes
frères ou cousin
il a rien donné il était un verrouillage
complet en tout cas tu as bien senti en
mode moi je suis là
parce que c'est du tourisme pur hein
Valentin moi je le vois bien alors
attends on prend une seconde quand même
pour se féliciter de cette réussite là
Morgane vous avez fait le même carton
que la première vidéo quand même je suis
très heureuse
d'abord c'est moi qui viens vente du
coup là ok j'ai mis la le journaliste à
la demoiselle parce que je les vois bien
maintenant qu'on sait en plus qu'elles
sont amis se dire que elles sont dans
l'audiovisuel toutes les deux mais je
les vois plus en technique et plus en
journaliste
mais journaliste me fun tu sais le quand
pas du tout
je vois bien travailler journaliste un
peu truc un peu décalé Canard Enchaîné
journaliste sportif
les trucs un peu comme
il peut être commentateur sportif même
tu vois et là c'est lui qui tu as non je
sais pas lui il est il aime beaucoup ce
que je dis en tout cas et rappelons
c'est son frère quand même non mais
chiffre et patrimoine ça va pas si mal
ensemble juste
ah mais attends
c'est contrôleur de gestion
c'est lui
non non mais un contrôleur de gestion
c'est celui qui va détecter ce qui est
positif ou négatif dans une entreprise
et qui va prendre les décisions c'est
des éléments très importants ils doivent
avoir un gros esprit d'analyse
j'explique bien ton métier peut-être
parce que la cigale si c'est pas lui que
c'est quelqu'un d'autre et que je dis
n'importe quoi il y a une personne qui
dit pas du tout
je vais cumuler avec science depuis tout
à l'heure mais parce que sur le Stringer
le salle de Stringer
[Rires]
la demoiselle pourrait faire du
journaliste aussi en horlogerie Audrey
marche bien aussi je propose qu'on les
valide au fur et à mesure audiovisuel
100% sur toi est-ce que c'est correct tu
peux dire la vérité c'est correct
audio on peut faire soit science
journaliste mais on voit qui a raison
pour la demoiselle elle est super trop
bien ok
ni l'un ni l'autre je fais des horloges
pour moi les journalistes à 100% travail
dans la science mais dans la science
plus la recherche
Sofia est-ce que c'est bon ou pas et si
vous voulez
et voilà
alors là elle sait jouer de nous en fait
je fais du des lives et j'anime des
émissions dans le jeu vidéo donc en plus
de mon métier
meilleur conflit que tu as proposition
parce que du coup les deux étaient bons
c'est parfait trop bien on est trop fort
c'est quand même le sciences qu'elle a
pris tu as raison on peut essayer mon
gestionnaire de gestion ça n'existe pas
contre l'heure de gestion
est-ce que oui ou non Eddy nous la
vérité vraie et tu contrôleur de gestion
trop bien merci je te laisse le prendre
aussi moi j'ai envie de tester lui juste
avant toute chose la gestion de
patrimoine en fait ce que j'avais adoré
tout à l'heure si on se souvient
des images c'est que à peine il s'est
assis tu as dit non patrimoine il a été
flash et j'ai envie de le tester ton
intuition flash parce que c'était faux
quoi
et c'est quoi ton métier exact du groupe
gestionnaire patrimoine donc exactement
ce qu'elle t'a proposé de faire tout à
l'heure c'était mais toi tu as dû avoir
une sueur tu voyais bien rentrer dans un
bureau et qui m'explique comment gérer
mon argent je me le fais pour principe
et tu oui oui dans la vente
et c'est un grand oui c'est un grand OUI
donc il nous reste journaliste
ingénierie
l'ingénieur en packaging
[Rires]
[Musique]
où il y a besoin de sourire
[Rires]
c'était pas lui casser ça peut faire
face après sur les stéréotypes basiques
c'est la seule personne par exemple qui
a du vernis à ongles aujourd'hui tu vois
qui va jusqu'au bout de son propre
packaging personnel tu vois ça c'est du
olicard tu vois et tu ingénieur juste
ingénieur dis-nous si oui ou non oui
jusqu'ici tout va bien mais attention
c'est ingénieur en
packagings
bien sûr donc ça veut dire qu'il nous
reste un ou une autre ingénieur on
pourrait essayer de s'en libérer j'ai
fait un truc
tu me dis si tu es d'accord c'est toi
qui valide et donc du coup si je te suis
plutôt dans ton avis les journalistes et
il est ingénieur parce que je vois pas
l'inverse qu'on passe en check ça es-tu
oui ou non ingénieur informatique
ingénieur ingénieur informatique
es-tu oui ou non dans les métiers du
journalisme exactement ce que vous avez
dit
ça il peut être commentateur sportif
même tu vois et là c'est lui qui tu as
moi je te voyais commenté c'est ça que
je voyais parfait
journaliste ou horlogerie on commence
par qui franchement les deux je trouve
que c'est possible parce que là
est-ce que oui ou non tu travailles dans
le journalisme
ah voilà on aurait dû inverser attends
on est face
tu travailles dans le l'horlogerie
vraiment dans la mécanique tu crées
l'horlogerie
et donc tu travailles dans le
journalisme tu es journaliste tu sais
quoi journaliste je m'occupe des
journalistes je n'ai planifie moi je te
vois bien être assez forte dans la
gestion d'un groupe le management la
planification ce genre de chose tu vois
on vous applaudit merci beaucoup merci à
vous merci et bravo moi je prends des
leçons de mentalisme quand je t'invite
sur ma propre chaîne incroyable je pense
que je suis très observatrice j'adore ça
et c'est incroyable à quel point
certaines personnes vont bien ensemble
vous mal ensemble c'est étonnant tu sais
il y a trois ans moi je m'étais dit je
sais pas si elle est énormément de bol
mais ça me paraît pas possible parce
qu'elle avait elle avait été trop juste
bon ben là on a confirmation
tous les ans on vient faire une petite
vidéo
ce concept on l'a jamais repris c'est
avec Clara ou avec personne incroyable
comme ça je bosse moi quand tu es là
parce que tu trouves des trucs à ma
place merci beaucoup d'être venu merci
de m'avoir invité aussi sur ton cabaret
l'autre fois on se refait ensemble le
cabaret Clara Morgane je vous mets
toutes les infos dans la description
prenez soin de vous abonnez-vous à très
bientôt Ciao